Thanks you for the kind introduction.
Uh, unfortunately what he said is wrong.
I'm not the best one to to explain it.
Um, so
again you chose wrong. Yeah, I'm sorry.
So yeah,
the I think Pedro will be the best one
to explain it.
Um anyway so we'll uh start today with
the basics of adsft. So today there will
be no super symmetry, no integ. So very
simple I'll try to explain the basic
idea uh behind
ADCFT. Um and then um probably for the
next two lectures if uh well there are
many if you have many more questions
about this I can try to answer them in
the next lecture. So otherwise I'll go
into describing more how to use
integraability to analyze some problems
in
ADSCF and there we will definitely use
super symmetry in the theme of this
school. Um okay so ADSF is
a is really I think a bad name. Uh so
the this subject should be called
quantum field theory slash quantum
gravity duality. Um but sometimes it's
also called the gauge gravity duality
for reasons that will be clear in a
second. And the basic idea is an
equality between uh you take a spacetime
um and you consider quantum gravity in
this spaceime in the interior of this
spaceime. So this whole
interior and then this should be equal
to a certain uh quantum field
theory that is defined on the boundary
of that spaceime. Okay. So that's the
ads this uh quantum field theory
uh slash quantum gravity
uh
duality is just this statement the
statement that these two things are
equal. Now um we have various examples
where uh we'll give a specific uh space
time here and a specific gravity theory
and a specific uh quantum field here on
the boundary and there are various
examples of this. So many of the
examples uh involve uh string theories.
Uh so that's string theory is a is a way
of um quantizing gravity.
Um and uh when we have strings, so if we
have strings here in the interior in
particularly in particular if we have
weakly coupled strings uh which is one
regime of quantum gravity then typically
the gauge theory that is dual to it uh
will be um a un gauge theory.
um you engage theory usually in the
large hand limit. So and you need to be
in the large and limit because um um
here strings have a coupling and the
coupling uh between uh between the
strings turns out to be uh proportional
to 1 / n^
2. Now um the reason uh this is the
coupling comes uh well it's due to an
old argument uh of toft that if you have
a un gauge theory you can um uh divide
the diagrams the fineman diagrams of
that gauge theory into planer diagrams
and non-planer diagrams and non-planer
diagrams um are suppressed by powers of
1 / n^ squ and this amounts to and turns
out to be exactly the same as the
division we have here in string theory
between string wall sheets which have
the topology of the sphere or string
wall sheets which have more complicated
topologies which represent string
interactions. Um okay that was a very
quick um review of the to argument but
uh basically since u since that argument
it was expected that uh large gauge
theories uh should be related to string
theories of some kind and
uh people thought well maybe those are
string theories that somehow live in two
in four dimensions the same number of
for example if you started with a gauge
theory in four dimensions people
expected those strings to live in four
dimensions but actually those strings
should be thought of as living in some
higher dimensional space. In fact, uh
they they live in this the interior of
this this other
spacetime. Um now in gauge theories we
usually have a a gauge coupling and um
so there is the yaml's coupling and not
to be confused with the string coupling.
Um and the effective coupling in a large
engage theory is G square N. And the
reason for that is that
um is that we can have n uh colored
objects uh or n gluons propagating
between
uh that that can transmit the force and
so interactions are n times bigger than
you would otherwise expect.
So
um so in other words if uh you have the
propagation for example of a gluon and
uh you have this type of diagram um
there is a color line here which can
have n different colors and for that
reason this diagram gets enhanced by a
factor of n. So really the effective
coupling of these theories is g square n
and so if you have a large engage the
theory this this will be the coupling.
So whenever lambda and this is sometimes
called the to coupling lambda and when
lambda is small uh the gauge theory will
be weakly coupled and it turns out that
in uh this relationship the radius of
the space here so some measure of the
typical curvature radius I'll be more
concrete in a second um the radius of
curvature of the space that is somehow
the size of the space uh in uh string
units is typically a power of g square
to some positive number
here. Now the fact so string theory can
be well approximated by gravity whenever
this uh number is very big. So whenever
the size of the space is uh much bigger
than the string scale. So in other words
the picture is something like this. So
we have some very big space.
Um and uh the graviton is a little
string uh whose size is of order the
length of the string. And in order for
for you to be able to approximate the uh
the string state by a pointlike particle
such as the graviton of Einstein's
theory, you need that the size of your
space is much bigger than the string
scale. Okay. So gravity will be a good
approximation whenever this is much
bigger than one. And I said before that
um perturbative gauge theory so weakly
coupled gauge theorist your usian
intuition of gluons moving almost freely
interacting now and then uh is good when
this is very small. Okay. So um now the
regime where these two theories these
two approximations are easy is perfectly
incompatible and that's uh good news
because otherwise we would have ruled it
out immediately because uh the theory
here doesn't look any anything like uh
perturbative gauge theory.
um and that's also why it's called the
duality. So that's where the word
duality comes from is the fact that um
the parameter space is is divided into
two regions and in one region of
parameter space one description is
simple in the other region of parameter
space the other description is simple.
Okay. So here in one one regime
perturvative gauge theory is simple when
lambda is small when lambda is large the
string theory description is correct.
Okay, so that's uh the basic statement
and we'll uh give more and more uh we'll
specify it more and more. So that's uh
somehow the basic
story.
Um
now in order to understand this a little
better, one needs to understand better
what kinds of spaces we're going to be
talking about here.
And the spaces are
um spaces which have something called
the warp factor.
Um war factor is just simply a
gravitational potential.
Um so there are spaces where for example
if we start with a theory which is
defined in R4 so we have the time this
is R3 comma 1 uh and they have an extra
dimension let's say C^²
um and then we have here a gravitational
potential which depends on the
coordinate C this just some overall
factor of the metric um when a factor
multiplies uh the metric in this lorens
in variant form is sometimes called warp
factor. Uh you might be also used to red
shift factors which are factors that
just multiply the time direction.
Um and so
on. Um now what happens when you have a
situation like this? Well
uh just let
me so the types of metrics we'll
consider this factor will be such that
it diverges for sequel to zero. So
there's some region where it blows up.
Um and then uh it uh in some examples
the simplest examples like the ones that
have more symmetry they just decrease
continuously. But for the purposes of uh
illustration let's imagine a situation
where this war factor just goes up
again. Okay. Now imagine you have a
gravity in a situation like this. Um you
have a war factor that has a minimum at
some
location. Okay. This is just simply
gravity. This is a gravitational
potential. Well, so if you have if you
put in a particle somewhere, its energy,
let's say you put it at rest at some
position C, its energy would just simply
be the rest mass of the particle times
the local value of the war factor W of
C, right? And the particle will want to
go to the region where the war factor is
minimized. So the particle will want to
sit here at the bottom. Okay, that's a
gravitational potential.
Now uh imagine we have a situation like
this and we concentrate on the lowest
modes. So we concentrate on the uh modes
um where the particle is just stuck here
and moving purely in the uh
fourdimensional directions. So then
clearly the physics of this particle I
mean this particle will behave as a
fourdimensional particle right.
Um now if we uh do quantum mechanics of
course this particle will have some wave
function and it will have a wave
function localized near the minimum of
the potential. Um and again from the
five dimensional theory we go to a
fourdimensional theory. Now this is
nothing surprising. You of course know
that in uh many situations let's say
condensed matter for example you have
electrons moving let's say in a two
dimensional confined to a to a two
dimensional layer. um by a potential in
let's say the C direction and they
behave as two dimensional particles. So
that's uh that's fine nothing surprising
here. Now imagine we start including the
higher modes. So there is this wave
function and then there are some other
wave functions where it oscillates twice
and so on. Right? So these are all the
higher modes representing the radial
oscillations of this particle. Right?
This is more or less like a particle in
a harmonic oscillator will have all
these various modes. So then uh you
would say well you have a certain
four-dimensional field theory with um an
infinite number of particles you would
say because you have an infinite number
of particles because you have all these
various kalousa climb modes
right
okay now this is what you would naively
say
naively you have an infinite number
of fourdimensional particles
And now this fact that you have an
infinite number is the reason why if you
have a quantum field theory let's say on
a box and you want to include um and you
want to treat that's a field theory in
one less dimensions well it's useful as
long as you consider energy scales less
than the box when you consider energy
scales higher than the size of the box
it's convenient to go to the higher
dimensional field theory and it's not
convenient to think of it as a field
theory which includes all these infinite
number of
particles.
Okay. Now, what happens um in a theory
of gravity is that there is a kind of
truncation um and I'll a kind of
truncation that allows you to keep what
essentially is a finite number of
fields. So, you are able to describe
this whole configuration, this whole set
of uh states and so on, everything in it
uh in terms of a finite number of
fields.
and well there are various qualitative
reasons why this happens. Uh one is the
so-called horroric principle that tells
you you can describe the uh degrees of
freedom in some region of space by um a
number which goes like the area. Another
more practical is that if you try to
excite here very high kalousa climb
modes you might end up forming a black
hole um and that truncates them
um so and in fact in this duality to the
um this duality we're talking about this
un gauge theory has large by finite 10
so there's a finite number of degrees of
freedom which is described in the
fivedimensional uh
spacetime okay And this finite number of
fields uh this number of
fields is uh turns out to be
proportional. I I'll explain later why
it is proportional to this. I'm now just
giving results. It's proportional to the
radius of curvature of this space.
Uh well it's basically it's proportional
to the inverse of the Newton constant
the fivedimensional Newton constant uh
in units of the radius of curvature of
the space. So that's uh the number
finite number of fields you need to
include.
Um now a very special case of this uh
relationship. Now you shouldn't be
confused by thinking perhaps my
explanation was a little misleading in
that you shouldn't think of these fields
that will describe uh the field theory
as being directly these kaloosa climb
modes. We'll see that these koosa climb
modes we're talking about here are
really bound states of the fundamental
fields. All that I wanted to illustrate
here is just this truncation in the
number of fields and why it's important
to have gravity. Actually in one of the
exercises I proposed that you
demonstrate that if uh you have you have
a here an ordinary quantum field theory
then it cannot be dual to a quantum
filter on the
boundary. Okay. So it's crucial to have
gravity in the bulk.
Now, now let's consider a special case.
Uh and a special case is a situation
where
um um this factor w is equal to 1 / c.
Okay. So in this situation we have a
gradational potential of this kind and
uh the metric in this situation has uh
an extra
symmetry. Um so let me so we have all
the four dimensional fourdimensional
directions plus the extra direction
divided by c ^
2. Okay so that's um the metric and
um this metric has a rescaling symmetry.
So if x goes to lambda x
um and c goes to lambda c um this metric
remain I mean the the metric remains of
the same form. So that's an isometry of
the metric. Um and this um will
translate into a symmetry of the
boundary theory. So in this case uh the
boundary corresponds to uh these
directions um this the the four
dimensional directions. So the boundary
is whatever sits at C equal to zero. Um
so in general the boundary occurs
whenever the uh war factor diverges um
and when it diverges in this particular
way um the theory is conformal in the
traviolet. So if it behaves like this in
near the boundary uh you'll have a field
theory which is scaling variant
um because this bulk symmetry so the
fact that we have this symmetry in the
bulk theory translates into a symmetry
of the field theory of the field theory
and that symmetry is just symmetry under
rescalings.
Um
okay now let let me uh continue talking
about the physics of this work factor. I
mean the most important thing to
understand uh in the gauge gravity
duality or one one very important thing
to understand is uh the significance of
this uh scale factor what it does to the
physics and uh what what happens under
this very big gravitational potential
that we have.
Um so uh let's try to understand what
happens to a massive particle. So we
discussed before uh the fact that if we
put a massive particle here at some
point on this potential we'll have uh it
will have an energy measured with
respect to that time. So here um so
there is the time t um and we have time
translation symmetry and under and uh
translations of this time t. Um and if
we measure energies conjugate to this uh
time translation so the we have the
operator that implements those
translations in the H silver space blah
blah blah. If we measure energies
conjugate to this um uh we'll we'll find
that the energy of a particle at
position C is uh just given by well the
same formula I d written before M R* um
divided by C 0. Okay. So if this is a
particle sitting at some position C
0 that uh will be the energy uh at that
position. Of course if we put a particle
at this position C 0 it has a
gravitational force and it will start
moving in right. So a particle put at
this position will start moving to the
interior of ADS. And if a particle has
this energy uh and it comes from the
interior it will reach to this point and
then bounce back. Okay. So a massive
particle will never be able to get to C
equal to zero. Okay. Um so it will
always bounce back before it gets to uh
this
boundary. So we said that equal to 0 was
a boundary. Notice that this is a place
where you can't quite reach with massive
particles. You try to send a particle
higher and higher energies. You get
closer and closer to C equal to zero but
you b you bounce back before you get to
equal to zero.
with massless particles it's slightly
different. Um so uh massless particle in
principle can uh a massless jodisic can
get to cel to zero and the easiest uh
way to see that is uh to uh look again
at this uh at this metric and notice
that massless particle doesn't care that
there is this factor 1 / c^ squ um and
then uh you find that you have really
half space I mean you have in the c
direction uh you a light ray can come
and then go back out.
Okay, but really I mean they can do it
but at the cost I mean when they get
here they are really really uh very
redshifted and uh by putting a simple
boundary condition here and we'll we'll
specify later the boundary conditions
also massless particles uh go back in
and in general we'll have to supply some
extra boundary condition here at the
boundary of ads to tell us how these
massless particles are reflected.
Okay.
Um now notice that um as we uh as this
particle has as we move this particle to
smaller and smaller values of of uh of C
not it will have higher and higher
energies.
And this is the first uh manifestation
of uh of something which is uh we'll
we'll see later in more detail which is
the fact that
um uh approaching the boundary of the uh
of of ads corresponds to going to very
high energies in the boundary especially
very uh high energies offshell energies
in the boundary
theory.
Um now this can also be seen by noticing
that if you take the scaling symmetry
and you perform perform rescalings that
move you to smaller values of C that is
you choose here lambdas which are
smaller than one then you're also going
to exits that are smaller than one. So
in the boundary theory you are shrinking
your distances you're examining the UV
behavior of the theory.
Um now in fact uh when it turns out that
if you uh have a particle at some
position C 0 so a massive particle at
some position C 0 it corresponds in the
boundary theory to some object some
object some bound state some state in
the field theory which has some
characteristic size which is also
proportional to C
0 and again this is this is also due due
to this just simply the application of
the symmetry. So if C 0 corresponds to
some object of some size then as we
rescale it, it will rescale together
with C0. So um sizes here on the
boundary um on the boundary theory
correspond to um to this distance from
the boundary in the bulk. So a pointlike
particle in the bulk corresponds to an
object that has some non non-zero size
in the boundary and as we approach uh as
we approach the boundary this object
shrinks and becomes smaller.
Okay. Now this is also another one way
to think about the merchants of the
extra dimension. uh the fact that uh in
a conformal in a scaling variant theory
in order to specify the state of some
object you need to give not only the
center of mass position but also its
size and so you need one more coordinate
than you would na have expected and this
one more coordinate is uh this extra
position in the C
direction.
Okay.
Um now uh let's talk a little more about
uh this space. Um it's called this space
it's uh called anti-seater space if I
haven't I think I already said it. It's
the simplest space with constant
negative
curvature and um it has it has more
symmetries that are that than they are
apparent in this
uh in this way of writing the metric. So
I've uh written the metric in such a way
that you see the pankar symmetries plus
the rescaling that I've just mentioned
but it has a few other symmetries which
are called special conformal
transformations
um and so on. So by writing the metric
unfortunately there is no coordinate
system that makes all the symmetries
manifest. So you'll have different
coordinate systems make different
symmetries
manifest.
Um okay so but there is another set of
coordinates that uh are particularly
useful for thinking about antic space
and these are coordinates uh where the
metric takes uh the form uh d to square
cosine hyperbolic of row plus d row 2
plus sin hyperbolic of row 2 d omega 3^
2. We are talking about the
fivedimensional anti-sear space. Now
um there is some overall factor which is
telling us the um the radius of
curvature of the space. Uh we have the
metric of the sphere. This would be the
radius of the sphere. This just setting
us setting the scale of the space.
Um and so in these coordinates the space
can be actually in fact the pendros
diagram of the space can be represented
as a cylinder. uh with one time
dimension and then this circle here is
really uh the s3 and then we also have
the radial direction that starts from
the origin of the
cylinder.
Okay. Now imagine we uh consider a
ukidian field theory for the time being.
So ukidian field theory uh will be
related to ukidian ads space and ukidian
ads space also is known as hyperbolic
space it's the same you can represent in
the same way but with a plus sign here
yes the term multiplying das is that ln
what is that hyperbolic cosine I'm sorry
I I learned with Russian books which
write write this as uh
yeah sorry sorry about that.
Um, okay. So
the so if you if you have the ukidian
field theory um then uh you can map the
ukidian field theory to a cylinder uh by
considering something called radial
quantization. So you start with some
origin and you think of time not as
slicing the theory in this way but
slicing the theory at different uh radi.
Okay. Now here the size of the sphere is
changing but um we have of course the
conformal symmetry that allows us to uh
change uh the overall scale factor in
the metric. So this is now the metric of
the fourdimensional filter in uklidian
space. We can multiply this metric
divide this metric by R 2 and so we get
here log of R 2. Now we have a cylinder
uklidian
cylinder.
Okay. And then the theory on this
uklidian cylinder is dual to the theory
on the ukidian version of this space
which we could also now we could
analytically continue the time
coordinate in this cylinder to Lorenian
signature and we would have this
Lorenzian signature space. Now the
reason I mentioned this uh this
relationship in detail between the plane
and the cylinder uh is the fact that um
if you start with the quantum field
theory on the plane and do this mapping
here you get um the the on the cylinder
on its ground state. So you get the
ground state on of the the cylinder the
state with lowest possible energy. But
by inserting local operators here of so
you insert some operators at the origin
and you do the same mapping then here
you get some excited states uh on of the
theory on the
sphere.
Um so you have this
um this mapping between
operators in
R4 and uh
states of the theory on well
on S3 times time.
Okay. So this is uh something that is
true in any conformal field theory in
four dimensions but it's actually true
in any dimensions. You have to only
change the dimensions here of the
cylinder. Um and it follows just from
the simple argument about the val
rescaling symmetry of the theory. The
rescaling of in a conformal field theory
you can uh change the metric by any
overall factor and the physics will be
the same. Okay. Um up to something
called the conformal anomaly which is
not important for what I'm saying here.
Um
um okay so now we have this mapping
between states uh operators and states
uh of course uh here we have this ads
space now we uh can view the filter as
living on the boundary so this is just
the boundary of the cylinder this is a
cylinder with the interior and this is
the cylinder without the interior that's
where the filter lives and different
states here correspond to different
states uh here in uh in the bulk. So in
particular uh imagine you have a
particle here sitting at the the center
of ads. So you have some particle and um
we can compute the energy of this
particle with respect to that time uh
that time coordinate that appears in
that metric and
um so the energy of that particle will
be uh m times the radius of ads if it's
sitting at the
origin now and that will be the energy
of the corresponding uh state here on um
on the boundary theory
and such energies are related to uh the
behavior of the state and their um
translations in this direction which is
the same as rescalings of this
coordinate r and so uh that value is the
same as the conformal dimension of these
operators. Okay, so those energies are
the same as the conformal dimension
usually denoted by delta is the
dimension of the operator. Well, it's
how the operator scales and their
rescalings of the coordinates. So we
have this relationship between the
operator dimensions and the energies of
particles. Now of course when uh we did
this we did this for a massive particle
and I I've ignored quantum effects. So
ignore the fact that this particle can
move and has some wave function. Uh um
so in other words
uh notice here that uh this
gravitational potential again is like a
some harmonic oscillator potential.
Well, it's not really harmonic,
unharmonic, let's say. Um, but it's some
potential and due to quantum effects,
there will be some quantum uh
contribution to the energy of the
particle. And you can do that quantum
mechanics and it just simply corresponds
to solving the wave equation for a
massive field on this curve space. And
you can calculate that energy precisely
and you you'll get the precise
expression which for a scalar field uh
has the form 2 + square root of m r 2 +
4. So I'm not telling you how. So this
is the full exact answer. So it's exact
in the regime where you can
calculate well it's not quite exact. I
mean it's it's only exact in the
approximation where you consider you
take into account the quantum mechanical
effects of the particles but you do not
take into account the back reaction of
the particle on the geometry.
Um okay.
Um
good now this uh formula uh shows a
couple of features
that so first is uh consider a massless
particle. So particle m equal to zero
um that would correspond to uh an
operator of dimension delta equal to 4.
Um so first thing to notice is that a
particle with zero mass does not lead to
uh a state with zero energy because of
the ground in that case the only
contribution is just the ground state
contribution from the harmonic
oscillator potential. So there is that
contribution to the energy and that
contributes to a non-zero energy an
energy equal to four in this units.
Um not notice by the way that the spread
of the wave function here
um is if this has some curvature scale
of order one um the spread of the wave
function will be again of order the
radius of the the radius of curvature
right
um just even in the original formula
that we is some energy which uh goes
like the gradient terms you need for
curving so changing the wave function at
scales of order the radius of curvature
that contribute with a mass or energy of
order one / r that give a contribution
to the energy of order one. These are
the corrections we have to take into
account when we do the quantum
mechanical
calculations. Anyway, so mass equal to 0
will still have non-zero energy delta
equal to 4. Now delta equal to 4 in a
fourdimensional field theory is a
special uh dimension because this is a
dimension of a so-called marginal
operator. So we can um add this operator
to the theory at at least to leading
order the uh theory will remain
conformal. So this is a perturbation
which at least at first order in the
strength of perturbation it does not
change conformal
symmetry. Now there are many situations
where uh we have scalar fields with a
completely flat potential in the bulk.
The dilaton for example in some of the
examples in strength theory will be an
example of that. And in such situations
where we have no potential for the
diloton and the diloton have any value.
So the scalar field can have any value.
So the theory will be conformal for any
value of the diloton. And uh changing
the the value of the diloton would
correspond to changing the constant
value of that scalar field everywhere in
space. Okay. That uh that's what uh that
corresponds to.
Yeah. How do you know that it's exactly
marginal?
Yeah, that requires more calculation.
That's why I said if you have a
potential which is exactly flat then it
will be exactly marginal. Yeah, exactly.
That would require more calculation.
There are many situations where you have
delta equal to four states but they are
not all
marginal not exactly
marginal. Um now another interesting
case is the case of uh the
graviton. Um so the graviton again is a
mass particle which in the bulk has mass
equal to zero but now has spin two and
it also leads to dimension four state
which uh is just the stress tensor
operator on the boundary
theory. Um and that's the correct
dimension of the stress tensor.
Um okay so uh I mentioned a couple of
states. So in any uh conformal field
theory you will have you'll definitely
have the stress tensor. So it will have
the graviton in the bulk.
Okay. Um so that's a state that we'll
always have. Um and then different uh
other uh quantum field theories could
have other
states. Now let's analyze what other
states we get from the point of view of
the bulk.
Um well I mentioned that in many
examples we have uh string theories. Um
so string theories contain string states
and among the string states there are
the massless string states which uh
about which we talked a bit here about.
So we have those but in addition we have
massive string states. we have a mass uh
of the order of one over um over the
string length. Remind you that the
string length is so the tension of the
string is one over ls^ squ. So that's
the definition of ls. So we have a
string of this tension will have such um
such states and it will lead to
operators of dimension um r / ls.
Okay. So all the massive string states
uh will have dimensions which K like R /
LS and if you recall what we discussed
here. So we discussed that the gravity
approximation will be correct precisely
when R ls is very big. So precisely when
all these states have high
dimensions. Now if you go to just the
first massive string state um you'll
find that among those massive string
states there are there are states we
have spin bigger than two. So we have
for example states of spin four just the
first massive string
state. So
um um now if this state was very light
then gravity would not be a good
approximation. You have sort of light
states of spin 2 spin four you probably
are forced to include all kinds of
spins. Um so the approx the demand that
delta over ls is very big is given a
high mass to all the states we have h
have a skyer spin spin bigger than two
and make sure that uh what is remains is
uh what remains is are all the states
with spin two and therefore well and
probably the well certainly in flat
space the only consistent interactions
of low energies of spin particles are
those of gravity.
So this leads to a natural idea that
that if perhaps you have a conformal
field theory where all particles of spin
bigger than two have very high conformal
dimensions, you probably rec discover
gravity in the infrared. Though this is
a conjecture hasn't been proven.
Um anyway so
um but this is something to to remember
uh in particular is saying why um if you
had a why qcd for example will not will
not have a a nice gravity dual even for
n equal to infinity because there we
expect to have uh higher spin particles
like the resonance resonances we see
which have spin uh bigger than two and
uh which are not much heavier than
particles with spin less than less or
equal to
two anyway. So the gravity approximation
will not be arbitrarily good in those
cases. Um of course the string
approximation will be
correct. Now there is one important
property of uh of the spectrum that I
completely I
didn't I didn't mention and is the fact
that in in a weekly couple string theory
or in a theory of gravity that for large
radius you can separate the uh the
states according to single particle
states and multi multiparticle states.
So in other words the states can be uh
organized according to at least an
approximate fox space where you have the
state of one particle then you can add
one
particle will have some energy E let's
say E for the one particle states and
then you can have two particle
states which will have energy while the
energy of the first particle you put in
the energy of the second particle plus
some small corrections. So in a theory
of gravity the small correction will be
proportional to the Newton constant in
uh the
theory in these theories we're talking
when the gauge theory will be
proportional the correction will be
proportional to 1 / n^² and this
structure of large end gauge theories um
arises when you consider the div the
when you consider single trace
operators. So operators which can be
written in terms of uh many insertions
of the field versus uh operators which
are of this form for
example. So you can consider an operator
which contain two traces and versus
these operators. Now if if if you're in
the large limit in the regime where the
to coupling is fixed uh you can uh
compute the anomalous dimensions of
these operators and that will be a
typically hard calculation and my next
two lectures will be about computing the
dimensions of these operators. Um but
then the dimensions of these operators
will be just the sum of the dimension of
this operator plus this operator plus
some small correction.
Okay. And again uh this is a structure
uh which matches the uh the gravity
structure and it essentially boils down
to the same uh thing I mentioned here
about planer diagrams. So that len
theories uh in in the planer
approximation correspond to uh string
theories uh again in the approximation
tree level approximation that we have
this this expansion in terms of the
genus of the diagrams translates into
the statement that we have expansion in
terms of the genus of the
world. Okay.
Now
um now can a weekly coupled uh theory
ever have a gravity dual?
Well, a weekly couple theory always
contains a weekly weekly couple gauge
theory always always contains operators
of this form d plus
to to the s phi where let's say you have
two uh operators five could be f five
could be a scalar an an field in the
adjint and so on and we act with
derivatives on these two fields and we
can make a a primary operator out of
this thing. So something which it
transforms in an irreducible
representation of the conformal group
and uh these operators will in a weekly
couple theory will have a dimension
which is typically small. So it will be
of order s. So delta will be of order s
and in and so this is not much bigger
than well you could have let's say s
equal to three for example and uh it
will have a small dimension.
Um so weakly coupled theories cannot uh
have uh well cannot be well approximated
by gravity. So you'll have really to go
to strongly coupled theories where these
corrections that we get so typically
we'll get some corrections to the
dimension which of course depend on the
spin. Um and in theories that have
gravity duals uh these corrections
become very very big for all the
operators that have spins bigger than
two. So getting large anomalous
dimensions is fundamental for getting uh
a good gravity dwell that's what I'm
trying to say.
Um
okay so now um now that we discussed uh
all these operators we can uh start uh
computing correlation
functions. So in conformal field
theories the natural observable are
correlation functions of local operators
of these operators we've been
discussing and one of the main elements
of uh ADSCF or an element that is is
used all the time is the relationship
between correlation functions of local
operators and a certain calculation that
we'll uh do in the boundary theory.
So let's first start discussing an
operator which has high anomalous
dimension corresponds to a single
particle of large mass.
Um then in that case uh well anyway
before we say that the object we are
considering is this correlation
functions of local operators in the
conformal field theory. Um and now let's
consider for example the twopoint
function O of X1 O of
X2. Um now by scaling symmetry or
conformal symmetry this twopoint
function goes like X12 to the^ 2 delta
um times some coefficient which we can
set to one by normalizing the operator
appropriately. Okay. If delta is large
then uh we have this equal to zero. We
have let's say X and we separate two
points by some distance in the X
direction and we have a massive particle
in the interior. Massive particle can be
it's it's like it's well approximated by
a geodisic. So we have a judic that uh
goes between these two points on the
boundary. Now this follows from what I
said before though perhaps not uh very
clearly. So I discussed before that we
had this uh coordinates in ads space
where ads space looked like a cylinder
and there was a state that was a massive
particle that was propagating along the
time direction in the cylinder. Right?
And we also had this
uh uh state operator mapping in the
boundary theory um where a point here um
well where where we map the this whole
cylinder to radial evolution around um
around this object. So we can uh view
let's say one of these points as uh the
um this this point here and the second
point we can view it as some point at
infinity and then we have uh this
particle that propagates along the
cylinder the same particle that we
discussed before all that I'm doing here
is u making a coordinate transformation
that maps those two points from zero and
infinity to these two finite points here
and then the trajectory of the particle
corresponds to just this trajectory.
This is a semicircle and these are the
judics of anti-itter of anti-itter space
or hyperbolic space. Here I'm taking
this x to be spa in along a space-like
direction. So everything I say here also
will hold in hyperbolic
space. Um okay and again that's the
simplest way of getting the the the
jistics in hyperbolic space is to do
this mapping I just mentioned
um okay good so that's
um this is the picture now how do we get
uh this result from this
picture well um we need to consider the
bul theory now in the bulk theory um if
we have a particle will have um some
contribution to the partition function
that goes like the action of the
particle
right and this action will be equal to e
the minus m * the length of the of that
trajectory now you can come and evaluate
this length and so that's simple to do
um
we as I said this this is just a
semicircle so we have this semicircle we
can have this angle theta um now the
metric is uh the metric is over there.
So it's whatever the metric is for a
circle which is just the integral d
theta divided by that factor of c since
we have the square root of the metric we
have a factor just of c of theta okay so
that's the metric we need to evaluate
that's the integral we need to evaluate
the length is equal to this and we find
that it's infinite okay okay well that's
typical so you always get infinities in
conformal field theories um but this uh
infinity
um is due to the fact that um well we're
going all the way to the boundary the
boundary is infinitely far away so this
is just the same as the statement that's
of saying that the boundary is
infinitely far away so I didn't mention
that but in proper distance the boundary
is infinitely far away so in order to do
any computation you really need to uh
you will need to put some cutoff you
need to put some cutoff at sequel to
epsilon and uh really compute only up to
sequel to epsilon and then learn to take
the c the epsilon going to zero limit.
Now this is uh in correspondence to the
fact that in filter is we often well we
have to put some ultraviolet cutff
compute some quantities and then take
the ultraviolet cutff to um to
infinity. So what was um an ultraviolet
diversions in the field theory
translates here into sort of an infrared
diversions because here this is due to
the fact that the volume or the lengths
in in ads are infinite. Um so it's an
infrared story but it's an ultraviolet
story in the bound in the boundary
theory and this occurs over and over
again. Uh this is just the simplest
incarnation. Okay. So uh you can uh so
we need to integrate only up from C
bigger than epsilon and so if this has
some let's say size x um we have to
integrate up to a theta which is of
order epsilon /x and so this thing will
give a log of um epsilon / x okay where
x is either this distance or half of the
distance we don't care about these
factors of two
Um okay so what we get is for fixed
epsilon we get e to the minus m I forgot
the factor of r here which will give us
the correct uh dimension um times a log
of uh epsilon /x
um and this log is negative so you would
better get a positive sign here um get
that
um and so here you see a factor of
epsilon which you get epsilon to some
dimension and if we we were to keep
track of all factors of two, we would
get a two here. Um, and so we'll get up
to an overall factor that depends on
epsilon uh 1 /x to the two 1 /x to the 2
delta which was what we wanted. So the x
dependence is precisely the dependence
we had there overall factor that depends
on epsilon. So this epsilon to the power
2 delta is something we need to absorb
in the definition of the operator and
it's what's given the operator its
dimensions. Um okay very good.
Yeah. Um that's an
exercise.
Um, so
um, yeah, I didn't explain why it was a
circle, but that is in the
exercises. Um, yeah, I guess I didn't
mention the exercises, but I prepared
some list of exercises, and you should
get them probably tomorrow or or today
if I'll do it fast enough. But one of
the exercises is to show that theics are
a circle.
Um now
um now this derivation is perfectly
correct when uh mr is much bigger than
one. If mr is close to one again you
have to do the quantum mechanical
version of this. So you'll have to sum
or all paths and so and so on do the
path integral and that's just simply the
same as solving the wave equation
solving the classical wave equation in
this space. And again that's another
exercise. So um so the exercise consists
of so let me well it will be printed. So
exercise solve uh the wave
equation for a scalar field fi uh is you
might find it convenient to start first
with massless fields.
um uh it's a little simpler. Um and then
uh put a regularizator at scale epsilon
and you put some arbitrary boundary
conditions. So
um you'd say at uh c equal to
epsilon you put some arbitrary boundary
conditions 50 of
x and then you can solve the wave
equation.
And what that is supposed to give
you is the following.
So I'm going here to state the final
dictionary. So if you calculate in the
uh quantum field theory
you consider the generating function of
correlation functions for the operator O
that is associated to the scalar field
phi. Um this is an integral in four
dimensions on the boundary theory. Um
that uh is supposed to well it's
approximated u by e to the minus uh the
classical action for the scalar field uh
on the classical
solution. Okay that you have found by uh
solving the wave equation and setting
those boundary conditions at the
boundary.
Okay let me be a little more explicit.
So in the bulk we have
um an action of the form uh gradi squ.
Uh if we have a massive field we also of
course have its mass. Um so this is the
action. This is the bulk
action. So we are supposed to do is find
the equations of motion for this action.
Solve with this boundary conditions.
Replace it here back in the action. you
will get some terms that diverge with
epsilon blah blah blah and uh you get uh
also some terms which correspond to the
non-local part of the correlation
function of this operator. So in other
words uh when you do this the easiest
way to do it is in fer space. So you fia
transform this ph of p and so you'll get
things well you could also do it in in
position space but um five
zero well anyway um you can do it in the
exercises or or you can ask me questions
if you want
um now this is I put this here this
approximate sign um but there is an
exact version of this relationship
um
and The exact version of this
relationship is uh given by computing
the full partition function in the
gravity theory with the corresponding
boundary conditions.
So the partition function um in the
field
theory as a function of the
metric the fourdimensional
metric or
couplings and these couplings could
depend on the position and the metric
also could depend on the position is
equal to the full partition function of
gravity
um
with boundary conditions uh fixed by uh
the metric or by by those four
dimensional values of the metric. So
there is for example a 5D metric and at
the boundary at epsilon is equal to that
fourdimensional metric that was
appearing here. So here there is some G4
the fourdimensional metric
fivedimensional metric is set to this
value.
Okay. And so that's um that's the full
dictionary and in the regime where uh we
can neglect the gravitational back
reaction and so on and interactions
between these five particles. This is uh
uh this is correct. If we had the more
complicated action here which included
for example some five cube terms um then
uh we'll have also contributions to
three point functions for example right
and in general there will be a
perturvative way to evaluate the right
hand side here in terms of some diagrams
some sort of fman diagrams where you
start from some points in the boundary
where the operators are inserted here at
the boundary. These are also sometimes
called witten diagrams um where you have
some interaction f cube interaction in
the bulk and this uh these lines uh just
simply denote the propagators from the
boundary to the
bulk.
Um
okay
now. Okay.
Now it's very important in uh this story
that uh there we are supposed to sum
over all
geometries and we can also include
geometries which uh are different from
the original geometry um different
topology um but have the same boundary.
And the nicest example is the example of
a black
hole. So a black hole is a geometry
which is uh different than the geometry
of the original ads space but has the
same boundary condition. So you can
consider a black hole inside anti-itter
space. it um asymtotically you'll have
the same anti-ter space you had without
the black hole. Um but inside you'll
have something with a different
topology.
Um now you can also have things uh which
are called black brains. So in this
situation where we have the C direction
and we have let's say the x directions
along here we could consider a black
brain. So a black hole which is extended
along the three spatial directions of
the theory. So this is a state that uh
is translation invariant in the three
spatial
dimensions. Um and uh there is such a
solution uh it's uh given in the
exercises. So that's some explicit
geometry which uh here is very similar
to ads space and it has a horizon here
at the position at this
position. So it has a horizon and
subosition
c0 and the position of the horizon is uh
related to the temperature in the
boundary theory. And now what could be
the relation between the position of the
horizon and the temperature? Do you need
to work any do you need to do any work
to find this relationship at least the
scaling? What determines the
relationship?
Is it for example temperature to the
three temperature to the two minus one
mass right it's mass dimensions
right it's determined by uh scaling
right so we need to understand under
deation symmetry d scales like mass c we
set scales like length so with minus one
okay okay no work that's nice okay there
numerical coefficient which you cannot
get through this argument
unfortunately. Now then we have uh the
free energy which
uh which can well obviously now that you
learn how to calculate this using
scaling you also know how to calculate
this guy and so what is how do you
calculate this one?
Well, first of all, you need to make an
important assumption. Well, which is
kind of obvious, which is the fact that
it will be proportional to the volume in
the three dimensions, right? So, it's
infinite because we'll have infinite
threedimensional volume. So, it's
proportional to the volume in the three
dimensions.
Um,
right.
[Music]
Um, and well, so this is the total free
energy. So, this is the thing that
appears in the action. is dimensionless
and so the rest of course uh has to be
beta to the minus 3 or t t cq.
Okay. And then there is some coefficient
here in front. Okay. Now what will the
coefficient in front be
um how much calculations do you need to
determine this coefficient in front? So
let's we would like to understand the
dependence on the newton constant of the
coefficient in front.
So this is some calculation that will
come from uh evaluating the action of
some solution. The action is just the
action of the uklidian version of this
black hole that will give us the free
energy and it is um well the action of
gravity is 1 / gton times uh the action
I mean the usual action square root of
gr plus blah blah blah
right. So one thing we see is that uh
well it will involve one over gon. So
because it's whatever action we had
there um none of what we said so far
depending on gon the black hole solution
doesn't depend on gton we evaluate this
we'll get something and uh we'll have
some gton in front of course the
something we get here is what's going to
give us this part right that we already
determined and all we are determining
now is one over
gton now but gton is an object which is
dimensionless in the is dimensionful in
the bulk theory and uh it should um
become dimensionless by absorbing powers
of r the radius of
ads. Now dimensions in the bulk are not
related to dimensions in the boundary
theory. That's important. So we're not
going to cancel the dimensions of gtonm
by some power of t that that doesn't
work because um recall that uh the be
rescaling what it does is an isometry in
ideas right um it acts as isometries in
ideas they don't uh have any dimensions
if you wish uh from the bul point of
view so this dimensions of this guy have
to be fixed by powers of r and in five
dimensions just that are
cubed anyway so this is a prefactor. And
now if you compare this with a free
field theory, so in a free field theory
you get something similar to this. So
beta f um is something similar to this
except that you have the effective
number of degrees of freedom.
So
right so I mentioned in the beginning of
the lecture that the effective number of
degrees of freedom is proportional to
this number and if you wish this is the
derivation of that fact. Okay. So when
we consider the thermal
uh partition function of this object
which is computed the thermal partition
function of the boundary theory is equal
to uh the hawking gibbons hawking
partition function for the gravity
theory um corresponding to this black
hole um and we get this answer
and are there any questions?
Now in theories that come from gauge
theories uh this number is typically
going like n squ
um in the of course in the free theory
we can calculate it but um in the bulk
theory well we have this formula but we
can't necessarily match the numerical
coefficient. the numerical coefficient
could be some function of the tooth
coupling which in principle we have to
compute.
Um yeah maybe I guess maybe at this
point we can make this plot that so as a
function of lambda you can calculate
that n effective over n^² and for one
particular example of uh this duality
which is the case of n equal to 4 supery
which uh we'll discuss uh in detail uh
tomorrow. Uh we find that uh if we call
this one here um that's the value at
weak coupling uh this uh is a function
of the to coupling which goes
between one and
3/4 and we really only know uh these two
parts of the function. Um so we know
what it is at very strong coupling. We
know the first stringy correction. we
know what it is at very weak coupling
and we know uh the first
correction there at weak
coupling. Now what I'll discuss tomorrow
I'll discuss similar calculations but of
anomalous dimensions of operators where
we can actually compute the full
function that interpolates between weak
and strong
coupling.
Um okay so far uh we've been discussing
um yeah one more thing to say about
these black
holes. Um let me can erase probably
here.
Um we can calculate correlation
functions in the presence of a black
hole. And so we have this black hole and
we compute the correlation function. So
as as we said the correlation function
corresponds to the emission of a
particle and then a reabsorption of the
same particle. Um and now if you emit a
particle and there is a black hole what
will the particle want to do?
Yeah it will want to fall into the black
hole of course. So it's very unlikely
that the particle would come back out
right and the longer you wait. So if if
you send it in and you would say oh wait
I want to detect you back then probably
the fact that you have the black hole
doesn't matter too much. But uh if you
wait for a long time then um it's very
unlikely you'll see the
particle. So in fact if you compute such
two point functions uh you find that
they will decay exponentially with time.
So this is some time t
um with some number that and to compute
the number you really need to do some
calculation. Well of course you can
compute how it depends on the black hole
temperature. That's not too complicated.
same story that we discussed before. Uh
but the precise numerical coefficient
you have to do some calculation. Um okay
it's some number actual number divided
by beta. This is the same as what we
discussed before and that's how they
will decay. Um so they decay because the
particle wants to fall into the black
hole. And in the language of black
holes, what happens is that um this long
time tail, so this number here um is
related to the so-called quasi normal
frequencies of the black hole. So here
you can consider excitations around the
black hole and they're not quite energy
states because they're falling to the
black hole. So the frequencies of those
states are have a real part and they
also have an imaginary part and this
imaginary part tells you about these
long time tails.
Okay,
good. Now
uh in the particular case that you
choose this operator to be the stress
tensor, this uh correlation function
tells you something about uh how um how
the black hole uh responds to small
pushes. So you push the horizon a little
bit in one direction and then the the
fluid this thermal fluid in the boundary
theory will respond in some way or the
horizon itself will deform in some way
and uh it will lead to different
expectation values for the stress tensor
at later times. So you can view these
two insertions of stress tensor assigned
well you deform the metric a little bit
to give a little push to the fluid and
with this one we just measure how the
fluid um is moving
um well I'm I guess I'm probably going a
little fast but um I probably should
have mentioned that uh of course this
finite temperature configuration is
breaking um the boost symmetry of the
problem right so you're you have your
fourdimensional conformal field theory.
You raised it to finite temperature. Now
it's filled with some thermal gas or
fluid. Uh it's not really a weakly
interacting gas. I mean it's something
that where the particles are interacting
very strongly. Um and now uh this fluid
we have properties um will as any uh
good fluid they will obey the Navier
Stokes equations and so on. And um you
can calculate the coefficients appear in
these nav stocks equations like for
example the viscosity by uh doing such
calculations. So the viscosity tells you
how you are dissipating energy and
um these exponential tails are related
to that. So they are related to how if
you shake this a little bit how quickly
that information about that shaking dies
out. And that um that's related to
dissipation. Now in general the the
slogan is that
um falling into a black hole is the same
as dissipation in the in the boundary
theories. In the boundary theory, you
have this thermal gas and you start with
some excitation localized excitation and
this excitation low slowly thermalizes
and becomes equilibrated with the rest
of the gas and that process is described
uh in the dual gravity theory by a
particle falling into the black hole.
Okay. So you can compute this viscosity
um the sheer viscosity which is the only
viscosity you have in a conformal field
theory and it's related to the
absorptions of gra absorption of
gravitons and absorption of gravitons by
a black hole are uh prop they are
proportional to the
area but now you uh remember that um the
entrop is also related to the area. So
you think that it might be a good idea
to divide the um this um viscosity by
the entropy and indeed you get some
number which this turns out to be a pure
number which is 1 over 4 pi and this is
a general result in um in any theory
that has a gravity dual and is correct
only in the gravity approximation. So
once you start including corrections
higher derivative corrections to gravity
this uh gets corrected and could get
corrected with plus or
minus.
Um okay what time am I supposed to stop
now
or wish? Okay as I wish.
Okay.
Um well the one thing I I wanted to
mention is go back to
um to the original diagram for the war
factor that I drew
um
and and try to say what it corresponds
to.
So in the beginning we uh drew a war
factor which uh had some minimum here.
Right now this is the typical situation
you'll get when you consider confining
theories. So some theories where there
is no mask up. I mean such a war factor
does not have the conformal symmetry
anymore. Uh so these theories will have
a mask up. Now here the war factor is
not that it goes to infinity again but
in uh the typical situations what
happens is that the space ends here and
there are different ways in which a
space can end. Um typically in the
examples there is some there are some
extra dimensions let's say an extra
circle which uh has some fixed size here
and infinity and then when you come here
it shrinks in a smooth way together with
the radial direction uh in such a way
that gives you smooth geometry. So
that's one way it can work. I mean there
um but basically the space ends here and
then if you consider a a particle
um the the minimum energy for a particle
of mass m will be achieved here at the
minimum and that minimum energy is non
zero. So um and any excitation you
typically want to put here even a
massless particle like a massless
graviton will be forced to have some
wave function which is localized in this
direction and for the same reasons that
we saw in global ads. So this energy
will be non zero and from the point of
view of the fourdimensional theory
you'll have a non-zero mass for the
particle. So in this situation you
typically have a mask up. Um
um now sometimes in some very very
specific examples there might be
massless degrees of freedom that have to
do with flat directions of the field
theory and so on. Um but the typical
situation without super symmetry and so
on is to have a mask up.
Um unless well typically if you don't
have a mask up there is some good reason
either super symmetry is protecting it
or maybe there is some broken
spontaneously broken symmetry or
something like that.
Um now I mentioned that um the a
massless gradimensional graviton uh
gives rise to a massive spin to particle
in four
dimensions and you can do the counting
of degrees of freedom to check that uh
indeed this is consistent. The numbers
the numbers match between five and four
dimensions.
Um,
now okay.
So, what a few more words about the
radial direction. Uh, I
um I think I can't emphasize enough
perhaps
uh the importance of understanding this
connection between uh positions in the
radial direction and the sizes and so on
and the boundary theory. So let me
emphasize it once more. Um we mentioned
that
um we have this metric. This is the
metric of
ads. Um and all the computations that we
do uh usually in um that we do when we
match to filthy quantities we are
typically looking at something and
approaching the boundary at fixed uh
distance x. So we will approach the
boundary at fixed uh x
distance. This is sometimes called co
moving distance or and so on. I mean
it's called like that if you think in
terms of the sitter space. So this
metric is very similar to the metric of
the sitter space. So ds square this is
ads. The sitter space is the same thing
except that um there's a minus sign. So
deta
here. And so now we typically run like
this. Uh ETA here is less than zero is
conformal time again an infinite time to
the boundary. The boundary here in the
citrus is an infinite future. This is
just describing an exponentially
expanding universe. Um it's exponential
once you here go to the log of eta. Um
so it's exponential in the log of eta.
It's a power here. And um we have this
is the end of uh the sitter and here is
the very far
past. And again um this fixed uh fixed x
coordinates correspond to what's called
fixed moving distances. So you have two
observers who are just following judics
they would follow this fixed x
distances. Okay. Now you are probably
familiar with the fact that in the
sitter uh this distance is go to
infinity in the far future um and the
proper distance goes to infinity and
here again the proper distance is go to
infinity.
Now in the case of the sitter uh we know
we have horizons and that um anything we
um and this whole region becomes costly
disconnected from the observer that is
sitting here. Um and so any perturbation
that we uh that we do here will not
affect the observer that is over here.
So these two universes will once they we
reach a certain time they will evolve
sort of uh separately. So this is this
separate universe argument. Now here we
have exactly the same story uh governing
this uh behavior as a function of the
cutoff. So we do some calculation at
fixed x and then when we start moving
out um the same mathemats that here lead
to the two the separated universe blah
blah blah imply that uh the evolution as
we change epsilon is going to locally
affect each of these two guys
separately. Okay. And that's why uh we
we can extract uh so if we are computing
for example correlation functions we can
absorb this whole evolution in epsilon
as some local uh reormalization of the
operator and so on. And it's also
related to the fact that we get a local
filter on the boundary. So we have the
possibility of just changing arbitrarily
the metric here. It will not affect how
the metric is approached how the limit
is approached here. I mean it will
affect non-local correlations but not uh
the local behavior of of the
theory. So
um now there are some sim so there are
many similarities between the sitter and
anti-deitter and many of the partative
calculations you can do are identical
and you can translate very simply
between one and the other. Um now there
are some differences um and the some
some of the differences are that well we
can choose examples where anti-deer is
completely stable will not decay uh but
the sitter in all the examples we know
string theory will decay and there are
good reasons for thinking it will always
decay
um and and well also in the case of anti
there are examples where we know the
dual conformal field theory in in in
anti-citter we know that dual confform
formal filter in the sitter we don't
know whether any conformal filter really
exists or not
um but one thing I can't resist
mentioning is the fact that um the
quantity that appears there cg gravity
with fixed boundary conditions is just
nothing else than what you would call
the wave function of the universe so if
you let me draw this picture this way
now um we have now a ukidian space let's
say hyperbolic space some or or some a
locally hyperbolic face. It could be
globally different. Uh and uh or or we
could have perturbations blah blah blah.
Um and that quantity there should be
viewed as the wave function with some
fixed metric here on the boundary.
Right? So that's uh another way of
thinking about that object. C
gravity of course is the wave function
of the universe in some ukidian uh
regime. uh the one that appears in the
sitter is the wave function in the
Lorenzian regime more well real time
where things
happen
okay and so now um I'd like to mention
one more thing one more general thing
and
um that's u about global symmetries so
we often encounter um field theories is
quantum field theories with uh global
symmetries. Now imagine you have a
quantum filter with a global symmetry
then uh there is the corresponding
current uh conserved current and it
turns out that in the dual ads space
you'll have the current is associated to
uh gauge field a mu well this this amu
now has five indices rather than four um
and so we have corresponding gauge
fields. So global symmetries on the
boundary correspond to gauge symmetries
in the interior and that's good because
um global symmetries are exactly
conserved right they cannot be violated
in the boundary theory but we know that
if we had a global just purely a simple
global symmetry in the bulk we um black
holes uh could violate this global
symmetry formation and evaporation of a
black hole could in principle violate
these global symmetries but the
formation and evaporation of black holes
cannot violate gauge symmetries
And so that's at least one necessary
consistency condition for this to work
is that these global symmetries are
carried by gauge fields which uh black
holes can also carry. So they can also
carry global
charges and well similarly if you have
super symmetry you'll have super gravity
and so on. Okay I think I'll stop here
and continue with more details. So next
uh the next two lectures will be about n
equal to four super males and we'll
discuss that case in great
detail. Okay. Thank you.